[Music]
and bully bucks news
submitted by Wang Cho I like that
Chinese Korean tonight is a pillar of
Wing Chun and charming yet Starbucks has
bullied a small boba shop to stop them
from serving to go drinks I heard about
this [ __ ] well let's talk about this for
a sentence boba means Asian Asian people
either do bad things so let's continue
this that's a nice logo
so they are located in the shopping
center where there's also a Starbucks
and according to Starbucks is club in
their contract with the landlords not
allowed to have anyone else in that
complex have to go drink okay and so now
that this logo spot new Bo and MooMoo
it's called they started letting their
customers take their drinks to go and
then that's when the Starbucks lawyer
called them and said that they can't do
anything to go good because of that
contract and so now they're just saying
like you know we're just a mom-and-pop
shop we don't have a big lawyer to
represent us you know I don't think it's
that fair like people come here and they
they obviously want to take their tea to
go so it's not really fair
but the part that's unfair or dumb on
your part is that you decide to open up
your business knowing about that clause
and then then you want to change that
they didn't know at all they should be
pissed at the landlord the lawyer should
have contacted the landlord Starbucks
isn't in the wrong they're just
misinformed because the landlord's a
dummy because what's supposed to happen
if you are in commercial real estate and
you own a plaza or any of those food
courts you're supposed to curate it so
everybody can be cool and benefit from
each other so he could have seen this as
oh wait there's a drink shop and another
drink shop maybe they'll get into some
[ __ ] and there's some companies when
they negotiate they want to be the only
coffee or the only tea or the only which
makes sense you don't want to be in the
food court and have three different
coffee
so when Starbucks signed the lease when
they told the landlord they probably
arranged that we're gonna be the only
drink takeout but then that company the
landlord is probably like Asian or
something they're like no one's gonna
find out you get sell boba out the door
yeah this is an elk road outgrow oh
that's a Sacramento oh yeah yeah is it
largely like Asian
a lot of it nummies a lot of enemies
that sucks for the drink shop though
because being a mom-and-pop you put
everything into your first store
everything yeah
and then you pay everybody first and you
want everything to do well and I know
for a fact that drink shops a huge part
of your revenue revenue is to go drinks
I know because we have a drink shot and
by not allowing their customers to take
to go anymore it's hit about like a 40%
loss involved yeah people want to drink
so they could go shop yeah and then
people are like leaving angry from his
boat exactly because people don't
understand don't be like wait what do
you mean I can't take my drink to go
what the [ __ ] like that's so you should
be mad I just I think the thing that
gets me on the site it's not Starbucks
it's a landfill Emily they should sue
the landlord well I feel like that is
kind of predatory for Starbucks too
because really how why does that affect
you Starbucks should sue the landlord
like if your yeah it's like you so what
you know like I don't know yeah they're
saying that they feel like they're
getting bullied although I will say if I
love Starbucks like I freaking love
Starbucks I order a lot of drinks from
that but if it was right next to a bobo
shop I'd probably get a boba drink
instead of a Starbucks whoo that's
awesome cuz we're next to a Starbucks
there you go
when the Starbucks corporate lawyers
coming down they're probably just
looking at the clause they might not
even be looking at like traffic or like
how businesses can because they're
probably out to do so many kids so they
should but don't you think they should
attack the landlord since that's who
they exactly
I think that's exactly what's happening
that's not there thank you
yeah cuz they should be fine yeah they
didn't sign the contract with the boba
shop they sign the contract with the
land yeah the Starbucks has been there
for more than 15 years how can we
brainstorm some ways for MooMoo to find
a loophole
what if they they serve the drink in a
Gau Chinese takeout box like this all
bow but there now it's fool you know
what they shout food not ticket freeze
it have it frozen
but then the bones not taste good oh you
know this is what I'm not sure if you
guys are familiar with this but in the
github when we want to take our mountain
lick or we put it in a brown plastic bag
a brown bag brown paper bag and then we
serve it out and you have to pop the top
99 cents or toy like that kind of look
at then they're selling toys or if you
assemble yourself yeah
have all the ingredients separate and it
becomes a kit will you put it together
now it's a science project there's
always a loophole I would love that
jo straw bend it in half and put it into
the thing and now it's a slide for your
flavor buds slide and now it's a slide
drink it's a point [ __ ] that sucks I
think there's a lot of things that
happen in the in the business realm
versus like just common knowledge realm
and I think for most people all it's all
it looks like is here's big corporation
being a bully which they are but in the
business world that's what they're
supposed to do their predatory their
[ __ ] up and for the little guy you
want to be like David and take down to
Goliath publicity is the best way
because people get pissed and it'll be
like Starbucks will be like oh my god
this is such bad publicity we should not
do this anymore it's if it's an elk
Grove I wonder which one it's off of
Calvin all the [ __ ] Road that's the
one I used to always go to after high
school you know where that's at yeah
have you been to that barber shop
no it was awful cowboy that's the one I
used to go to all the time I hope they
stay bidding as well I mean now they're
on JK news now so all the fans in
Sacramento go to Moo Moo's go support
drink the drink inside the shop have a
good time and we just gave you like 20
loophole ideas yeah turn it into a drink
a simple drink oh just put a [ __ ]
big-ass Cal dildo in there then it's a
sex toy yeah
oh no then they lost all the family
business that's true well don't listen
to Dave yourself next thing you know
they're having like bondage meetings
there and then they're having all this
should embed it in apparel so you buy
merch and then like it's a hat well the
job oh no oh my bad that was it on and
then it'll be like different like flasks
built into the apparel yeah and then
just on it could be kind of sort of like
a speakeasy sort of thing where it's
like a secret to take the drink out or
you just do my plan once again which is
the brown paper bag they can keep the
same cups but just add a propeller so
then it becomes a toy so it's like
that's still toy drinkable or since is
tea and we're a [ __ ] is for medicinal
purposes they're actually just buying
medicine no just label it I'm a pseudo
claw supplement cuz you could just
register the business as a medicinal
company and they're selling medicine now
oh my god there's so many thing come on
MooMoo how to be illegal when a land
store yeah
how to be legal but legal how to be
legally legal talk to your [ __ ]
landlords because landlords sometimes
are [ __ ] [ __ ] I know I've been
doing with some business [ __ ] and that
must be [ __ ] crazy sometimes you have
to be flexible who are trying to open
our barbell in the same complex
mm-hmm and then they didn't want any
gyms here because it was against the
city code so we registered it as a
fitness studio owner it's akin to like a
dance studio but with barbells
didn't know like I never heard of that
before so I can't really so I can't
really reject that yeah awesome and you
never see Richard Simmons with little
one pound dumbbells going like this [ __ ]
that's exactly what it is just have a
couple of people dance in there a couple
every now and then yeah oh they would
dance all the time yeah boba is getting
so popular like the whole world is
getting on it and I think is awesome
yeah your husband mr. Steve green he
loves we always bring him boba and he's
always choking on the balls Hey
I know he didn't like it at first he
thought it was a texture thing so now he
likes it
I'm talking he's Asian he's lactose
treats boba he's pretty much a scene
right there did a lot of allergies he
claims to be more Asian than us because
he married that asian wife oh that's
right
that's right y'all went to the other
side the Anglos European Spanish that's
actually more rare like for the guide to
be Asian and they that is pretty rare
that's for daddy right mm-hmm
Asian guy oh my god white lady white
lady white guy Asian guy what well of
you guys I mean kind of random but have
you guys thought about opening another
bar bell oh I think we're gonna says we
got bullied somehow I thought you were
gonna ask if they're gonna open a boba
shop no thinking of opening a bar Boston
so you guys were talking about when you
opened it like the last time yeah we
want to but we got a perfect this one
that's getting pretty good right she was
a gym know her there you go in you're
gonna add group classes yeah training
cool looks like kind of like spin class
but for barbells Oh kind of like what
part of it like where there's the group
and they meet to train the same way yeah
so it's like that's it
what is the hands feet I want to see
that big but it'll be we won't have a
mic I used to take classes at the
24-hour fitness and we had this Chinese
lady that was doing a yoga class right
and she had that hands-free hat that's
it but you know Chinese women have high
energy and it was like the opposite from
yeah what do you want to hear and oh yo
guys okay now we're gonna come to down
dog downward dog and we're gonna go
straight up to the warrior tree and
we're gonna I was like damn slow your
[ __ ] rope
yoga my [ __ ] yeah I thought I was in
aerobics yoga class almost like and as
soon as I got in one position I'm in
another position Asian people when they
do like what you think perceive as like
American jobs it's like the funniest
[ __ ] because they never do it the way
it's supposed to be done and a man come
over and fix our [ __ ] garage I go
upstairs I come back down I see him
staring at it and he cracked open a beer
is this how we're doing it up
[Music]